The Witcher 3 will require around 50
gigabytes of install space on the ps4
and Xbox one
the developers confronted GameSpot
that's us I'm cam and this is a GS news
update
CD Projekt RED the Warsaw based studio
currently applying the finishing touches
to the highly anticipated action RPG
could not provide exact details on
install size at this point but following
a purported leaked PSN listing the
studio has confirmed that 50 gigabytes
is the ballpark figure PC specs for The
Witcher 3 which were released in January
had already suggested that about 40
gigabytes was necessary while this makes
the game a bit of a monster it doesn't
drastically exceed the other next-gen
offerings with NBA 2k14 and Assassin's
Creed unity both weighing in at around
40 gigabytes the sheer scale of The
Witcher 3 is apparently about 35 times
the size of its predecessor at about 20%
bigger than the vast world of Skyrim
which presumably has something to do
with the space requirement exactly how
much of that will be taken up by high
resolution sexy CGI butts and abs
however remains to be seen my bets
around 49 gigabytes The Witcher 3 is set
for release on May 19th through ps4 Xbox
one and PC but how does this news leave
you feeling
are you frantically calculating which
games you're gonna need to erase in
order to make up that space let me know
in the comments for more on this sexy
open world of The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt
why not watch our latest hardcore
gameplay reveal featuring brand new
footage and tasty Witcher details plus
these two jerks and of course for
anything else you could care to know
about the sexy open world of video games
come on back to Gainesville calm